alright hey everybody so much to talk
I am of course located in the Boston
area have been hearing helicopters
flying over my place for the last hour
or so and I have what I believe is a
live stream here in Boston the light is
looking feel like it's looking a little
darker if I look out my window than it
is here but I believe that this is
indeed a live stream this is from a
YouTube channel the resistance and not
that many people are watching this but
it appears to be someone here in Boston
and significant deployment of police
officers and we are listen I am hoping
that tensions deescalate tonight what
makes me scared that it's not happening
is that yesterday the president came out
after a weekend of just tweeting ajik to
call it and said hey even though
everybody's protesting police brutality
I believe we need more law enforcement
brutality Trump saying to governor's
yesterday if you're not strict enough
I will send in the military and be
stricter for you and the idea that you
are going to end or calm protests
against police brutality by telling
police and military that they need to be
more aggressive seems like the
definition of insanity to me let's see
what the audio is like on the street
[Music]
okay so a very very similar situation
here as to those that we are seeing in a
lot of different places we have any
number of different streams going on
right now some are carrying protests
live some are doing other sorts of
coverage this appears to be Los Angeles
California and Detroit Michigan and both
similar and different situations playing
out in different parts of the country we
have examples from all over of mostly
peaceful protesters demonstrating we
have examples from all over of some some
agitators who are not protesting people
who are showing up and doing other
things and those things are not good we
have examples of police that are
kneeling with or engaging with
protesters and saying we're with you
let's do this all peacefully and we have
horrifying examples of police officers
that are on video doing absolutely
horrifying horrifying things there are
allegations in some cases that police
are actually the agitators although I
want to be careful it's so easy to
accidentally spread disinformation in
situations like this that I want to be
careful not to do that okay this streem
I guess has ended so we will get off of
that we also have this other feed which
is from the woke channel on twitch which
has been carrying a number of different
feeds you see in fact one of the feeds
is the Boston feed we were just looking
at currently feeds from Indianapolis
Seattle regularly adding things and
taking things away and I'm glad to pull
up whatever folks are interested in me
looking at let's for a moment get back
to the Boston feed for the time being I
see super chats are pouring in
I see that people have questions over on
Twitch our great friend donkey show on
twitch has subscribed once again which
is it's just so great to see you donkey
show you've been a supporter for a long
time let me look at some of the own in
fact let me adjust this slightly there
we go I want to look at some of the
super chats coming in already Michael
says do you think Trumper authorities
will be able to label anyone anti feh
that they don't agree with or like if an
Tifa becomes a terror group it's very
scary stuff
if so and a power grab yeah there's a
concerted effort to essentially so I I
had a tweet yesterday let me see if I
can find it here oh I'll get to that a
little bit later let me see if I can
find it cccp oh boy everything going
wrong now let me see where this tweet
was we're gonna find it momentarily
there it is so I tweeted yesterday Trump
strategy is ironically cccp confuse
about what's happening in our country
conflate the protesters versus looters
versus rioters versus insiders criticize
meaning blame everybody else whether
it's governors Democrats or protesters
and then pander to his Trump is based
much of which loves authoritarianism
they often claim to be about Liberty and
libertarians but in fact they are very
authoritarian when it comes to being
authoritarian against those that they
don't like so that that's my thought
there
Zachary Monroe says is it in a war crime
for a leader such as Trump to order the
military to open fire on American
citizens listen you know it that these
are all different we have to define all
of these terms if you're thinking Trump
is going to be held liable for war
crimes forget about it that's not we
need to activate to get them out and war
crimes is not going to be what what
takes Trump down Walker Anderson says
your 15 minute video on the protest was
very well thought out gave me a new lens
through which to see this issue multiple
lenses I should say respect thank you I
actually did get some nice messages
about our coverage so far let's see what
this confrontation is here with Boston
police
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay a situation here in Boston I can
hear the helicopters you can't hear them
because of my elements of audio
equipment which have a noise gate and
block that out but I very much hear the
continued helicopters and horns all all
over I do look at the twitch chat while
streaming of course I love everybody on
Twitch and you can get your message up
on the that in you can get your message
in that vertical blue triangle if you're
watching on Twitch if you subscribe the
message will pop up and then I will read
it like for example he went to Jared
subscribed with the message hi David
you're cool which is a beautiful message
of peace and love
okay other YouTube super chats that are
coming in
incredible TV says David I'm applying to
be a journalist at CIN CNN can I
practice questioning with you and you
can tell me if I have a shot okay here
goes is Trump racist go to join
pakman.com to become a member I think
you're perfect for CNN absolutely zesty
African says boopy boobah on a scale
from one to the standpoint of water how
unlikable is Tom cotton whatever the
highest unlike ability number is
quadruple it and that's Tom cotton Nemo
Nova says just a regular subscriber and
Tristan mcoppins says don't you think
Trump somehow directed the police to be
brutal leading to Floyd's death and also
attacking journalists III think we're
we're stretching it if we say Trump is
responsible for for George Floyd's death
I think what we need to say is the
people who killed George Floyd or stood
aside despite being first responders
while he was killed are the people who
are responsible and and I think that
that's where we should really focus
focus our primary energy let me say
thank you to oh what's going on here
this was a great stream from from woke
on Twitch and it seems to have frozen
which is not the best
let's see if we can get that going again
ah there we go okay excellent excellent
excellent thanks to JPEG and faceplant
keggers for subscribing over on Twitch
Evan or Haleh says you see Matt Gaetz
tweet about aunty Fay disgusting you
know what I haven't I don't even want to
give him the time of day oh hold on a
second there's something here the super
chats aren't visible over there let me
see if I can fix that
okay so I believe now there we go there
we go ladies and gentlemen and let me
just correct this a little bit we'll
take this here and move that there and
then okay I think that we've got it now
yeah okay very very good and we'll even
trim it down a little we're just this is
this is an on-the-fly
sort of situation so I'm we're working
on this stuff as we go let's see here
Chad hold on let me see I don't want to
miss anybody Brent onea says first time
sending you some cash your channel and
takes on things are always super
interesting hello from Canada hope you
can vote out Trump I hope so too
Chad Rath says keep doing what you're
doing and thank you what's your take on
protesting versus riots and the White
House response listen you are always
going to have bad actors who want to
either cause chaos figure out a way to
get something personally out of what's
going on or simply incite for political
reasons we cannot allow Trump to do what
he wants to do which is to talk about
antiva as if an Tifa represents the I
mean is it hundreds of thousands is it
is it over a million people in total
that have gone out to the streets to
protest peacefully over the last 48
hours
we can't let it become you know this is
this is an Tifa protesters or protesting
looters are looting good cops are being
good cops and you've got bad cops being
absolutely brutal with the press with
protesters etc let's make sure that we
continue to call things what they are
Alan sac says CCCP is Russian for USSR
coincidence I think not
thank the Ismail for sending a super
chap Jeremy Landry says I'm fearing the
fallout of kovat cases from these
protests yeah I'm worried about that too
I'm worried about that too and here in
Massachusetts we are doing so well right
now and that worries me we're between a
rock and a hard place
and I'm not sure there's going to be an
easy way out from all this very well
said
thanks to octo progams
for sending some bits over on Twitch
inconsolable says via super chat where'd
that go
did you cover the Australian press
incident on the show today I haven't
checked it out yet I've not seen that I
apologize I'm not sure what would happen
comrade Mateus says do you think Trump
will deploy elements of military on DC I
I think that there's a serious risk of
that our friends from we act radio are
this stream right here in the middle at
the top in DC and we are keeping an eye
on that as well as multiple streams from
New York City let me pick up a little
bit more specifically on this element of
the stream from Boston Massachusetts
which is right here let's see what's
going on agreement about why the
protests are going on and whether the
police should be intimidated or not and
clearly this is a discussion that is
happening in Boston right now glad to
see that people are wearing masks
although taking it down and being four
inches from someone who also has taken
their masks down I do think is not the
the the the proscribed use of a mask
certainly but these individuals here are
figuring out what is the protest for
what is the protest for and that is a
it's a conversation that is taking place
if people have other streams that they
would like me to pick up I am glad to do
it this stream is trash right here and
it's oh it's Bloomberg okay yeah so
that's not a stream that we want but you
can't send links in the chat I believe
but certainly if you describe how to
find other streams we can we can go in
and check in on on what is going on for
sure because we want to I'm in Boston
but that doesn't mean everybody is so we
want to keep an eye on what's going on
in a lot of different places um Stephen
Hart says Stefan Hart says am I wrong to
be concerned that they'll there will be
a nasty spike of kovat in a week or two
you're not wrong to be concerned about
that that that is something I'm
concerned with black wave says bill de
blasio
is talking live okay I am interested in
what he is saying because he has been in
conflict with Andrew Cuomo let's see if
we can find de Blasio live okay I'm not
seeing that I'm seeing that he did it
eight hours ago
so if he's if de Blasio is live again
someone will have to tell me where that
is but I am certainly not seeing that at
this juncture Ruben loomio lemo says you
should on Twitter search operation
Themis I don't know what that is
III hope I didn't just say some code for
something horrible
James Aleppo says what's your basis for
believing our institutions are strong
enough to make Trump believe if he has
voted out I'm at the point where I'll
believe it when I see it listen if the
last 48 hours have shown us anything
it's that Donald Trump is not going to
leave without a fight he is not going to
peacefully transition but I believe that
he will leave if he loses and it's our
responsibility to make sure that he does
to make sure that he does Papa all
Vedado
says karma police arrests this man
Kingstown says I got my wife Cynthia
watching your show up now way to go
thanks Kings hounded hi hi to Cynthia
TR says have you seen Ted Cruz's bill to
designate antifa as a terrorist
organization and uses left-wing activism
interchangeably with n Tifa yeah that's
the that's the strategy first they say
these protests are really just an Tifa
which is of course not true then they
start to muddle the language between an
Tifa and left-wing protesters and then
they basically just make it a P
though left-wing protestors are mostly
not peaceful which of course they are of
course they are as you can see even from
from all of the videos that that have
come out today thanks to Drew Noah and
pusherman or pusherman for the
subscriptions over on Twitch I am glad
to take stream requests from people
there's a couple things I did want to
just briefly show you here I hope you
guys saw Trump at some point deciding
business over they gasp enough
protesters on the
thank you very much
the greatest country in the world thank
you very much greatest country there you
go nice and safe so there it is and of
course also continued reporters just in
the middle of it this is Jolene Kent and
again it appears to be a war zone
it's a sports field in Seattle security
team with all of our correspondents
Seattle police rear
hey juggling I don't love having you up
against a fence do you have a way out
there how do you even describe this
right okay maybe the best thing to do
here is for joing and her crew yeah
something hopefully closer to safety
looks like US News oh this is now a feed
from now this okay that seems to have
ended at this point in time so so that
is that and as you can see just just
it's not it's not even safe for media at
this point in time incredibly and we are
going to of course continue covering
that angle by the way I mean I guess
that I want to be clear this is not like
the most important thing right now but
when we talk about media it it I think
it's relevant to mention let me see
where I posted this on my Twitter page
I'm Deepak Minh on Twitter by the way so
this is what you called the soft
suppression of independent coverage of
these protests we spent the entire
weekend following and researching what's
going on in the country and we did a
show yesterday which had a lot of
stories about the protests and about
George Floyd and about police brutality
and and protest tactics and all this
stuff as you can see almost every single
one of our clips yesterday was
demonetised that's what the yellow
dollar signs mean now this is YouTube
the exact same thing happened on
Facebook okay so anybody who has fallen
for the idea that these platforms want
to encourage diversity of voices and
they want underrepresented views and
something other than corporate media we
did a show yesterday that was 90%
demonetised as you can see here so
listen I'm not the victim here right I
mean I could you know if this isn't if
this isn't if I can't make a living
doing this I can go look for some other
jobs certainly there's no question about
that
but the point is this is how you start
to suppress voices because if I want to
talk about as I said on the program
today a Kardashian lied about being a
billionaire or whatever those videos
will be monetized I will be doing you a
disservice I would be doing you a
disservice if I did that and that's why
you know when I see Super chats come in
from people saying you're doing a good
job with the protest coverage and
breaking down what is going on and and
narratives and the like I really
appreciate that because you know when we
spend an entire day producing a show
editing a show promoting a show research
you know all this stuff and then every
one of these videos almost gets a yellow
dollar sign on YouTube which means sorry
I can't monetize it and the same thing
happens on Facebook it's sick it's it's
absolutely sick and it listen we didn't
get killed by a cop we haven't been
tear-gassed I get it
but this we are we know what's going on
because of the coverage of it and when
you suppress alternative voices you are
essentially saying hey corporate media
whatever your story is is the story
that's going to be out there and that's
very very dangerous so nothing illegal
done by YouTube it's bad policy it's
very very frustrating and you know I
particularly obviously appreciate
everybody who's been signing up for
memberships on my website because you're
basically giving a middle finger to
these algorithms that D monetize and
before we go any further let me actually
thank so many people are signing up
right now and I want to thank those
people at join pakman.com Larry Mills is
new member number one mark Hancock is
new member number two miles Grier is new
member number three Mary Beth Jenkins is
number four thank you guys Wow Lucas
Arsenault is number five Deborah kenaf
has signed up at join pakman.com and is
number six jacob Hoffner number seven
I'm stunned by what's going on Alexander
Rees is number 8 M Liu is number nine
and also thank you to Riker Hardy who is
number ten and
Stephanie Kurtis is also number 11 I
can't tell you how much it means to us
that folks are supporting us in this way
and and I can assure you you know when
you when you do an entire show and then
see this it's it's not good it's not
good it's not good about what what it
says about a lot of these algorithms and
and platforms either okay other Super
chats coming in we are sort of just
taking a tour of what is going on around
the country right now we have focused in
a bit on Boston which is here we have a
couple of streams in New York City we
have a couple of streams in Washington
DC we act radio by the way this stream
these are our friends we're good friends
with the guys who run react radio and
it's great to have their feed and I'm
glad to pick up on some other feeds if
people would like me to just let me know
the chat and everything is moving so
fast so you can let me know via via
super chat potentially Nicki Cole has
subscribed with twitch prime and says
I'm pleased to help you out any way I
can also subbed on the website Thank You
Nicole and the Ron Burgundy is also a
new subscriber Zachary Foster says David
I think this isn't just about police
brutality the systemic issue also
includes career underemployment and many
other things yes check out my 15 16
minute clip yesterday about this where
what I essentially said is anybody with
a hot take that claims to know the
reason for what is going on right now is
missing the boat because this is this is
systemic in a way that is beyond it's
not just race it's not just
militarization of police it's not just
our economic system it's not just
coronavirus it's it's a lot of these
things are coming together in very
particular ways and I have a story about
that and you're absolutely right Zachary
for sure okay other super chats they are
starting to come in fast and furious and
I am I am missing some of them let me
scroll back up oh boy where are we
wow we have a lot here Dutch Morgan says
I used to be a Trump supporter I would
troll many left-wing streams I never
thought I'd change my political
affiliation oh wow
I did it because of people like you and
Kyle kolinsky I can't thank you enough
this is why it matters guys this this is
why this stuff matters you can Pierce
echo chambers it is possible it is
possible wade flores says hey david i
heard a report that the proud boys are
in my city my fear is that they're
escalating the violence and because of
that it's making it easy for policy and
government officials to blame an Tifa
any thoughts listen we know that some
supposed and Tifa thei twitter accounts
were white nationalists we know that
there is there are provocateurs that are
deliberately trying to make the
protesters who are overwhelmingly
peaceful look bad so i don't know
anything about that specifically but
there is no doubt that that very well
could be going on inconsolable says
google Australia asks for investigation
after police attacked two journalists in
the US for a New York Times article on
it I will check that out Carl Smith said
what if the art US Army fires on US
citizens I mean has it happened has it
been only police that have been firing
with rubber bullets or or I just don't
know I mean the National Guard's have
been deployed certainly and I don't I
don't know the answer did that I don't
know the answer to that
David Mello says have you shared any
thoughts on Biden's talk so here's my
thought about about Joe Biden's talk
today a couple different things number
one everybody who screams liberal media
they cover everything Trump does lately
I know they've not been covering the
press briefings and Joe Biden's very
good speeches about what's going on have
not been covered so here's my view is
Joe Biden a progressive hero no he's not
does Joe Biden in his past have
problematic positions of course he does
is there any comparison between Biden
and Trump right now when it comes to
leadership when it comes to a
willingness to say we have a systemic
problem here when it comes to police
treatment of minorities and generally of
the poor there's no comparison there is
no comparison whatsoever and I
actually tweeted earlier and this
resonated with a lot of people let me
see where it is where was it uh here it
is looking at my email the last 24 hours
seemed to have dramatically changed the
minds of many of my never Biden
followers I'm gonna have a bunch of
emails and tweets from people tomorrow
on the show from people saying I was in
I was one of those never Biden people
and the last 48 hours the Biden's speech
combined with Trump saying oh were
protesting police brutality let's be
more brutal and send the US military
have changed a lot of minds in a way
that I certainly would not have
predicted two weeks ago was going to
happen because we didn't know any of
this was going to happen thank you to be
scola who has gifted a subscription on
Twitch I very much appreciate that okay
so much going on April H says what do
you think of black lives matter and
their goals is defund or defunding or
dismantling police even possible no how
do we go forward from here love from
Toronto so I'm going to be publishing a
clip on Friday police is not going to be
dismantled or defunded okay so so if
that's what you're waiting for
I hope you're not holding your breath
because you won't be able to breathe
that that's literally the case so I have
an issue list of things that we should
be doing when it comes to police I'm
doing a full segment on this Friday so
I'm just gonna tell you what's in my
notes here are some ideas okay number
one in a lot of countries police train
much longer before they're out there
look at Germany as an example many other
countries in the u.s. very often you're
training for 12 or 13 weeks a few months
six months and then you're out there
policing that's not enough time and
specifically not only should police
training be expanded it should be
extremely focused on social worker type
work we know that social worker type
training for police allows situations to
be de-escalated it leads to better
community relations I'll talk about it
more on Friday but police need longer
training and more social work type type
training we will defuse a lot of these
situations from the get-go
number two we have
a lot of bad acts by police concentrated
among very few people I don't know the
numbers right I can't tell you whether
99% of police are good or 99.5% or 93 I
don't know what it is but what I can
tell you is whatever percentage of
police are not good they are responsible
for the lion's share of bad acts meaning
we have repeat offenders we absolutely
need two things as far as that goes and
this will be my last point I don't want
to do my entire Friday show today if we
had more personality and psychological
evaluation of police candidates we would
likely be able to root out that tiny
percentage that has bloodlust that as
Trump said are the guys who want action
Trump tweeted that about Secret Service
over the weekend that they put the ones
who want action on the frontlines if we
could root out that small portion early
we prevent the vast majority of the bad
acts
but then when there are bad acts there
should be a national database of police
complaints this would achieve two things
number one if I have a problem with
Boston PD and I want to try to get hired
in Austin Texas if we have a central
database it's much harder for me to lie
about my past with police now you might
say well okay Boston calls Boston and
speaks to your supervisor maybe maybe it
won't happen so we need a database of
bad actors and when you hire a police
officer you should be required whether
this is a federal law or it might be
states that have to legislate it if
you're gonna hire a police officer who
is not a brand new person that you're
sending to cadet school to Academy you
should be required to check the database
to see if they have complaints against
them so that police departments can't
hide behind we had no idea they didn't
tell us about their bad history well if
we have a national database and you were
required to check the database when you
have an applicant we would also prevent
a lot of these officers from getting
rehired because they will sometimes do
bad acts in one department and the
systems work and they're removed but
then they go get hired somewhere else
they don't talk about their past somehow
we don't know how the new department
doesn't find out about it so these are a
few ideas I see people saying Polly
unions are way too strong they would
never go for that it would be a fight
there's no doubt that it would be a
fight I agree with you but these are
some of some of some of my ideas when I
see if there's anything else to mention
when there's police shootings and uses
of force
you probably want civilians to be
involved in the review process and the
adjudication process it shouldn't just
be left to police that's another idea
police are overly militarized we need to
demilitarize a lot of other countries
police are not nearly as militarized and
you have far fewer problems so those are
those are some ideas but you know this
this is a big topic let me do a couple
other super chats and then we're going
to look at a few other things here by
the way if you are just joining us on
any platform Facebook make sure to give
our page a like twitch make sure to
follow my channel and YouTube make sure
to hit the like button and hit the
subscribe button it really helps us
David Belsky says my dad thinks you're a
dweeb but you do get it all right which
is what matters all right we'll say hi
to your dad for me I don't hold it
against him van a Dulles says
unfortunately I lost a hundred dollar
gift card I bought this weekend dang
sorry to hear that Seth Barham says
David have you seen the video of the
Tennessee National Guard laying down
their shields you can tell by their
faces they don't want to be there I did
see that video let me see if I can find
it and we can all look at it that was a
good video let's see here
Tennessee National Guard videos I think
we will be able to see it okay yeah I've
got it for you thanks for calling my
attention to it take a look here
[Applause]
badly-needed as this person says
badly-needed great to see that very very
a good video thanks for calling my
attention to it I'm glad to find you
know to pull up other things if people
are interested let me thank a few other
people who have gotten memberships and
and I so appreciate it
gene Gonzales is new member number 12
today Nolan Tarbox is number 13 Gerardo
Quintana is number 14 I also want to say
thanks to Todd Sandridge who just
grabbed a membership on my website vida
daniel is new member number 16 today
Paul Jacobs is number 17 William
Campbell is number 18 I'm unbelievable
Sam Weaver is number 19 Michael Keating
is number 20 I so appreciate you guys a
clifton marshall is number 21 today matt
Schweiger is number 22
Chris's Sidorov is new member number 23
today also thanks to Paul Arcas F ski or
our kazoo ski who is number 24 and Luis
riffle is number 25 you know when we get
to 25 I like to say let's let's go for
50 Michael McGowan is new member number
26 today Colton Boren is 27 and Jessi
Aguilar is number 28 I I'm not meaning
to take so much time for this but I am
stunned by the folks that are seeing the
importance of what's going on in
grabbing memberships I really appreciate
that okay let's go back to our Boston
stream and see what is happening here as
I mentioned I've heard a protest I'm
sorry I've seen protesters walking by
and I've heard helicopters for the last
of 75 or even 90 minutes let's see
what's happening here in Boston
yeah here you go we are here we are hey
hey let me refresh everybody's memory I
don't want y'all to think I'm not going
to Minnesota cuz that's still on my way
there I've got a little situation going
all the flight delayed I'm trying to get
a flight that's gonna get me out there
and get me back I'm going out there
yall already know what the news is okay
alright so a lot of discussion of travel
plans happening at this exact moment but
massive massive crowd
we did have destruction of property
two nights ago here in Boston I don't
know what happened last night
but it appears to be more peaceful today
everybody walking by my place seemed
very very focused on the the you know
the activism component of what is going
on so that is good to see and the Boston
feed of course one of the feeds that we
are monitoring here it just got a little
blurry let's see what we can do about
that
we want 1080p of course I wouldn't bring
you guys anything anything short of that
we have a feed from Atlanta Georgia
our friends from we act radio are in
Washington DC DC along with the Zack and
NAT show we have Jeff Macke in New York
City that was our feed from the
resistance here in Boston we also were
monitoring video from Columbus Ohio New
York City and Atlanta Georgia all thanks
to the twitch channel woke the twitch
channel woke bringing us this multi
stream of a variety of different I call
them elements of streaming is the way
that I describe it
thanks to plague of the earth and beasts
colo as well as nav Rees for supporting
over on Twitch very much appreciate that
oh by the way I've just because so I
somebody I get I don't know if it was a
joker for real someone told me a couple
weeks ago to make an account on only
fans and I tweeted that I did but it was
a joke I didn't really do it I did
actually make an account on cameo people
were also suggesting that I make an
account on cameo and I did that is not a
joke I've not used it yet
no requests on it I don't know if I'm
going to I've I don't even fully even
understand cameo but I am what is my
username Oh David Pakman okay I am David
Pakman on cameo and I don't know what
I've agreed to do I don't know anything
about it cameo reached out to me and
said hey I we get a lot of requests for
you I don't know if that's good or bad
but I am now on cameo and I will look at
it after the stream in case anything
happens on there but very very exciting
stuff I don't know
you know Kent cameo is CA Mei at C a.m.
yo is the way that it is spelled okay
other super chats are exploding we have
an explosive super chat situation I want
to hear from you
Aleksey DOMA knob says would Biden
pardon Trump I think he said he would
not already would it work to take a
supermajority in the house take the
Senate and impeach Trump without
capitulating to the electable dem
getting the Dems blamed for his actions
extremely unlikely
I think it's simpler to remove Trump by
electing Biden Joe Grover the effin game
cat says for some pizza for you and the
crew thanks for what you do monetized
[ __ ] oh my god aggressive Maddie I
speedy says David prior to this point in
time somewhere in the past the timelines
skewed into this tangent creating an
alternative 2020 McFly Brown 2020 okay
Paula White says Trump has caused all of
this and if you don't think that blacks
have it much worse than whites in
America you're an idiot and kovat is
going to spike like crazy because Trump
wants to cause a war aggressive Tom o
Wayne says have you seen the BLM
protests in Paris today I did see video
of that and it is stunning stunning
Johnnie Minogue says Boston resident - I
hated how the local news stations on
Sunday night were nothing but disaster
porn and spin that the protests were all
looters it was horrifying it was
horrifying
comrade Mateus linking me to the
Australian press incident okay I try not
to click on links on stream but I will
check that out later
James Buchi know says should the cops
military shoot and kill rioters no they
should not
Cameron Welty says I'm from Sea
and massive unrest has resulted from
cops pepper spraying and beating
innocent peaceful protesters Trump
sending in the military will be a
disaster yeah one of our one of our
feeds here was from Seattle although
that appears to be gone now but we have
been keeping an eye on Seattle because
things have been getting very very
aggressive there for sure
essential says thanks for your great
coverage I was worried but you didn't
let me down proud to be a supporter yeah
a lot of people wrote to me and said you
know David we just we really need a
community right now so even if you don't
do much other than pick up some of the
streams and let people participate it
would be a good thing to do so but I'm
doing what the people want I am here
doing exactly that
Greg Lerman sends a super chat so does
Cheryl who says thanks for your coverage
mone Lou says I just sent in my absentee
voter application but I had to print it
out it was not sent to me giving the
link to my whole family and friends just
in case of the second wave of kovat I
believe that that is smart I believe
that that is a very very smart thing to
do insane Lane says have you seen that
Australia is asking okay people are
mentioning that I don't know about it
yet so I apologize I can't comment about
it but I am going to look at that thanks
to Jason Girard for grabbing a youtube
membership tyka says thoughts on trump's
odd twitching and jerking at his awful
speech more coherent but odd behavior
yeah there was a lot of that it was he
was he was all over the place I don't
know what to make of it you all know
I've been following that for a while and
I don't I don't know what to make of
Trump's twitching and jerking it was
very weird cat McGlinn says how you are
doing well
stay safe and we are supporting you
thank you incredible TV says sorry about
being demonetized David I'm already a
member but I'll chip in however I can
your work is so desperately needed in
these times yeah if if you're just
joining us I put up a picture earlier of
how yesterday like our entire show was
demonetised because it's about what's
going on it's about police brutality
YouTube says Facebook says no no
monetization
it's about George Floyd any videos with
images of what happened
George Floyd are instantly demonetised
that's newsworthy right how what what
the policy seems to be is you can sort
of talk about what happened to George
Floyd but if you show the video of
course or even stills of what happened
demonetised so yeah I have a whole
segment about it I'm not going to talk
about that
hey this I think is Alex Lawson my
friend Alex Lawson from we act radio I
can't tell because of the mask I'm going
to see if I can pick up we act radio
YouTube let's see if I can find the
stream oh it just froze what does that
say live video interrupted okay let me
see if I can find the we act radio live
stream oh but then it doesn't actually
look that's weird it looks like they're
live here oh and now that stream is gone
okay so maybe we act radio is no longer
live that's too bad yeah we have old
friends that we act radio in DC and
they've been doing a lot of streaming
thanks to a de terre
for subscribing with prime over on
Twitch I appreciate that remember by the
way if you have Amazon Prime I don't
care where you're watching if you have
Amazon Prime Amazon gives you a one free
subscription per month and you can use
it on my channel on twitch twitch TV
slash David Pakman just connect Amazon
to twitch at twitch dot amazon.com free
it's free to you and it's great for us
which is exciting thanks to Bob Allard
says here's to your coverage a wake up
style sends a super chat Joe Grover the
effing game cat has subscribed Jonathan
McCartney sends a I believe that's 5000
yen oh it is it's Jonathan says I've
lived in Japan for the last nine years
and I am simultaneously well I just lost
it
I am simultaneously glad to be away from
all of this but my heart is aching
because I feel like I am witnessing the
complete destruction of every goal I
wanted to see accomplished during my
lifetime it's tragic
I don't know how else to say it but what
we are seeing is completely and
utterly tragic no other way to say it
message in a bottle has subscribed neko
princess says Trump's declaration of an
Tifa as a terrorist group seems to be
just one more of Trump stoking the
us-versus-them mentality among his base
absolutely no question about it
James Aleppo says can't imagine any
length including martial law Donald
Trump wouldn't desperately go to combat
a loss on November 3rd and he has checks
and balances and the military wrapped
around his finger he is not going to go
peacefully we are going to need to
ensure that the institutions of the
United States do not get co-opted by
Donald Trump because if he loses he will
not go peacefully I believe he will go I
believe he will go but I don't believe
that he is going to go peacefully papa
or louie dado
forgotten dad says I've been drunk since
the impeachment hearings ok film mariage
has subscribed Ruben Lemos as aircraft
over DCA last night in a show of force
against George fort floyd protesters
were ordered by Trump operation Themis
AP correspondent James LaPorta ok
I have not independently verified that
Jeremy Landry says Trump letting 40
million people go unemployed during
kovat might have filled these protests
in terms of numbers of people able to
participate 100% I absolutely believe
that that is the case let's see what's
happening here in Boston to not take it
for what it is man
[Music]
what station is this seriously
oh it is oh this is this is actually
this is a little bit good sign it in its
in the city but it is man that downtown
is it it's interesting the forest
there's this busy
you've got transit police Boston Police
and it look like
[Music]
a lot of men put a lot of let's see it
just observe a little bit of what's
gonna
he hire enemy lines JA I'm behind enemy
lines they just come down and scoop on
me anytime they can sweep on the
resistance anytime this is what I bring
to you go this is what I do and I say
cheat on my word follow up news in
Minneapolis finally what news in
Minneapolis I'm behind enemy lines it's
getting rowdy out here but it's still
peaceful they try to light fireworks I
knock that [ __ ] out the area I'm not
playing that [ __ ] I could get over here
in ten minutes but it's it's seeming
like you know we could I can do more
good from the studio quite frankly
[Music]
okay all right so things very very much
going there and I'm glad to I would love
to pull up a New York City live feed to
see what's going on there let's see if
we can do that New York City protests
live I want to see what's going on in
New York um let's see
NBC New York let's see what's going on
here
chopper 4 over New York City protests
okay so you have a group that is
crossing the street right now and we can
keep an eye on this as well maybe
there's a better New York stream that we
could pick up also local news is likely
to get us you know what bad news bad bad
bad news could happen by picking up
something like that so if somebody has a
oh the curfew is enacted in New York
City and I'd be curious to see what is
going on there somebody has a feed for
me I would be glad to pick it up okay
let me say a few other thank-yous to
just incredible incredible supporters
that are signing up on my web site
Francis laliberté is new member
number 29 today Richard gray is number
30 John Johnston is number 31 thanks to
Karen Crenshaw you are new member number
32 today who else do we have Daniel
Matias oh love it is new member number
33 today and then who else did I not
think oh I think I have a couple of
other people hold on now it's now it's
actually getting crazy here let me see
where I was
thanked Myles Maribeth Lucas Arceneaux
we did okay got it and loo like a hearty
Stephanie okay and Wayne Jackson Wayne
Jackson is new member number 34 today
thank you guys I really do appreciate
the support and we are doing everything
we can to continue and expand the
coverage of what is going on around the
country right now okay let me read a few
other Super chats thanks to Erika hello
Freddy and angel Aguilar some random
says from Australia essential says what
are your thoughts on campaign zero I
don't have any real position on it I
don't know enough about it Vann Dulles
says might as well use this card up
Cheers Thank You cmk has subscribed Sean
Conklin says thanks for covering this is
le domaine Nico says I feel like Trump
wants civil unrest to justify his
actions and we should pause the protests
until we can vote in November what are
your thoughts I believe that there's a
good chance Trump will use the protest
to say it's too crazy to vote by mail
out it's too we can't vote by mail
because look at all these people they're
gonna steal mail from people's mailboxes
and it's gonna be crazy we've got a vote
in person of course the idea that when
there's protests you should vote in
person actually seems counterintuitive
but I would not doubt for a second that
Trump will try to justify not voting by
mail on the basis of the protests Trump
is going to try to justify not vote
voting by mail no matter what the facts
on the ground are that's the reality you
have to understand giant pants says I'm
so proud of all the protesters we need
good vibes cat McGlinn has signed up on
YouTube Kevin dis Landy says love that
you're covering this gives me a little
hope for Humanity that people are
covering this topic even though you will
probably get demonized I will be
demonized and demonetised and I don't
know if you meant he monetized Jake
Johnson says KTLA channel 5 la police
chief zooms session with the city yeah
KTLA is one of the worst that they will
they will take down my channel almost
immediately
Lou Angulo has signed up Ben Jason says
Trump in the DC police claimed no tear
gas was deployed at Lafayette Park
despite videos of them blatantly doing
it yeah I think I have a video that we
used on today's show where you can
actually see that let me see here Rose
Garden statement at the video where is
it oh when was that video of the I mean
here's one video just very quickly that
I'm able to find from what was going on
I believe in listen you've started to
see the big ass
what am i doing this
no okay this was not the right video oh
oh hold on a second here it is
[Music]
there are better better videos I
apologize that's not the best one but I
don't know how anyone can deny that tear
gas was used yesterday to clear the to
clear the path for Trump to walk over by
the way did anybody where let me see if
how I can do this
did anybody see how Trump was holding
the Bible yesterday he was holding the
Bible like like listen I don't hold
Bibles but I know that you don't hold a
Bible like this or however he was
holding it it's like you know when you
hold the Bible there's the thing you do
right where you there's a way you hold
the Bible and people who have ever held
the Bible know exactly what it is and at
one point Trump shook it like he like my
seats bouncing up and down he was
shaking the Bible which is a really
weird thing to do let me see if I can
find the video because it is just
bizarre bizarre where is it here
actually I think I'm just gonna have to
search for it
Trump Bible and then we'll go to videos
where was we I want to get a good shot
of this thing this is Trump walking over
there Oh backwards and upside down no
that's not it Oh God where is the good
Trump Bible video Trump Bible maybe if I
if I do Trump Bible Church I would find
something well that's a weird video what
is this this is a bizarre video
stop-in unexpectedly to this church okay
that's a strange video I've never seen
oh here it is okay let's see if he does
the shake here
okay
he was asked by the way I don't know if
you guys caught that Trump possessed is
that your Bible and he said it's a Bible
that means no we know it's a Bible okay
let me see if I hey it's our friend Ben
Dixon let me see if I can find Trump
shaking the Bible from photo no that's
audio all right I'm struggling to find
it now but in any case it was really a
very weird moment when Trump kind of
like shook the Bible up and down okay
enough about Trump and Bibles at this
point and Bibles as props obviously
super chats continue to come in ken
Clive says did you see what Los Angeles
cops are doing violently address
arresting people driving home in their
cars damaging windows of local
businesses and shooting rubber bullets I
guess you mean into people's homes I did
not see that I have not verified whether
that is or is not going on so I I don't
know that that's true I'm not saying
you're saying something untrue I just
want to be careful if I don't know about
something I don't want to endorse it
Robert Mifflin says odds that Democrats
win president and Senate does this help
or hurt so I think Biden has a better
shot of winning than Democrats have of
taking the Senate it's an uphill battle
in the Senate but certainly there is a
path and we've talked about what that
path is a number of times now and I've
done some some extensive videos about
that already
Dan Ali says cops can't even stop police
brutality in police brutality protests
do you think Trump will try to use the
army or Marines to stop the protesting
he said he will so I mean it's not my
opinion he said he will some random says
USA needs a stronger welfare system I
agree
doc says do you think Trump will invoke
the insurrection act I I don't know you
know Trump often threatened things and
then doesn't do them okay let me get
over to our good friends at twitch.tv
slash David Pakman things getting pretty
wild in Atlanta right now as you can see
major major major crowds 11alive youtube
let's see if we
can find that specific stream let's see
where this is 11alive YouTube here it is
just pulling it up for you fine folks
and here is the so this is you know this
is risky because we're going into local
news stations but I do want to take a
look at what's going on up close in
Atlanta so here we have so it's 901
there just as it is here they seem to
have more light than we do curfew
beginning soon let's listen in
[Music]
I mean listen you know it's these
situations are really tough because you
come into it at some point there's
reports that bottles were thrown at law
enforcement there's a curfew and law
enforcement is dispersing tear gas who
started it what what oh you know this is
why these situations are so complex and
difficult I'm against throwing stuff at
police and I'm against having police act
aggressively and punch people knock them
over tear gas all of the stuff I'm
against all of it once you start doing
one can you say that the other is not
obviously going to happen right I was
gonna point out even before we got to
this point it was like right now on the
ground right now it's men that were
there we're gonna pop in and go to hope
for it right there were times that
construction fencing is being
deliberately destroyed as you can see
deliberate looks like destruction of
this construction fence as the gas comes
out our crews are getting out of the way
right now is this is unrest if I've ever
seen it before going off people jumping
fences and trying to get out of the way
of the tear gas crews moving in within
the first three minutes of this really
about just 30 seconds into the nine
o'clock hour so there is if you look at
the ACLU on protesting one of the things
that they will say is once law
enforcement tells a crowd to disperse
there they're supposed to what is
supposed to even mean they're supposed
to give a reasonable amount of time for
that to happen you don't go hey curfews
9:00 p.m.
903 we start beating the crap out of
people and throwing the gas if people
are moving away when you ask for a
dispersal the right thing to do is you
obvious I don't think I need to tell you
guys you don't tear gas them you don't
start beating the
crap out of them that that doesn't seem
to be what's going on here there's
questions ever about whether you know
the military should even even be here at
all let's listen in a little bit more
this this is getting very very ugly and
I don't like to see it yes getting word
from our producers that hope and her
photographer okay here they're talking
to us and communicating
although that scene look pretty dramatic
we are thankful to report that they are
okay even though hope wasn't wearing a
mask she did get out of there in time
enough so I am seeing that the
Washington Post seems to have coverage
in DC so this is what's going on in DC
let's listen in here
[Music]
[Music]
so it seems as though this is the White
House there's an extremely bright light
and actually are these multiple lights
are they using some kind of annoying
light to try to annoy protesters that's
I've never seen that before
people say that things are getting bad
impossible someone can
[Music]
all right so that's Washington DC here
is Boston we are an open area we walk in
with the police and opening area this is
a peaceful protest so this is OK with
police and believe is walking and we
with people are walking with them ladies
and gentlemen we the people are walking
with them
I know people who live right by here I'm
trying to let them know that this is
going on so that's in one part of Boston
I want to see if we have any other I did
want to see downtown Boston Boston
protests live I'm worried things are
maybe getting a little bit not so good
in downtown Boston but I'm not actually
able to find any other let's see
ZQ oh here we go hold on a second oh no
this is just an overhead shot okay if
anybody actually has video of a
different Boston protest where it is not
going as well as this one I would love
to know about it but this one actually
seems okay I want to keep an eye on this
a little bit more people protest way
down here we walk in with the police
okay it's the other way around they're
not walking with us we're walking with
them we the people are out here walking
with them we are the champions my friend
okay
[Music]
this is not Brockton this was this
started at the Forest Hills tea station
and it is going down what looks to be
Washington Street by the MBTA bus depot
right here if I know if I believe I
understand exactly where this is this is
Washington correct me if I'm wrong if
somebody knows this is this is a
Washington Street yeah right that I know
this apartment building here and people
walking down Washington Street how do I
describe it even
I guess chords Jamaica Plain
[Music]
okay we're gonna keep an eye on that let
me read a couple of other super chats
that have come in whoa whoa a bunch lost
a lot of them okay
tear gas did you see what la cops cops
can't stop police USA need stronger
welfare let's see where we were make it
simple call his son he's watching the
protest - I'm not gonna call her son
right now
space magic right now it's important to
promote Ally ship be an ally keep up the
great work
Ryan Walsh has signed up Amanda Oh says
thank you David anything live in Chicago
I am Not sure I'm not sure but we have a
number of different feeds going Paula
White says funny how demonetized sounds
like demonized which I get a lot being
an atheist love your work keep it up
telling my boys all for to watch so
they'll know the truth always Thank You
Paula I appreciate that
we are watching a protest in Boston head
from the forest hills here's how to this
is basically walking from the Forest
Hills Orange Line stop in the direction
of the green street orange line stop
that's essentially where this protest is
going like us says do you think the
police allowing looting is to give
optics to a false right wing narrative I
don't I actually think that it's a
police tactic where you bet you
basically control the space and you you
allow some destruction of property in
order to broadly maintain control of
what's going on I don't know that it's
so politically based in that sense and
and calculated necessarily Carlos Gomez
says Church that Trump went to asked
Trump to repent
Benjamin skolas drah says I suggest
checking out nine News stream of Denver
very large peaceful gathering outside
Colorado capital and other group
marching through the streets I will find
that and we will also look at it so this
is 9 News News Denver and then they have
a stream going right now we will pick
that up as well in a little bit ok we'll
get back to that it's earlier there so
we're kind of working our way east from
places where curfews are
indeed starting okay Oh says I'd look
into what's been happening in Brockton
okay Peyton Pelin says my dad is an avid
from pastand is basically a completely
different person since his election
Trump must go ASAP keep up the good work
David sorry to hear that JD says how
much responsibility does Trump share in
the record-low black unemployment rate
and is it even is it that as remarkable
as it seems no listen unemployment was
just low and we can argue how much
responsibility Trump has for that but
there's no reason that when you have
really low unemployment that it wouldn't
be low for every group so that is that
that is sort of that let's refresh here
it looks like we may have lost this feed
did it go down it looks as though it may
have gone down yep and then I'm getting
messages from people who are living on
that street in fact who are seeing it
walk come come by okay let's take a bit
of a look now at what's happening in New
York and New York now under curfew and
this is from a chopper with New York for
NBC a lot of streets are of course very
clear and then we also have video from
Denver I am told this is one of the most
peaceful protests let's take a listen
and not much listen to
gonna be hard to hear much from from a
helicopter anyway but yes this does seem
at least from what we can see right now
very peaceful and quite well organized
and you love to see it when it goes this
way you love to see it when it goes this
way for sure looks like the Boston feed
may be dead
here is Colorado we also have Washington
DC this is I this is the White House
right I mean this appears to be right
out front of the White House can anybody
confirm for me I sort of recognized this
area
okay so it's calm there that's okay
let's get back to our multi-stream to
see Oh Atlanta oh okay
Atlanta genuinely seems like things are
getting pretty pretty wild they are
abiding by the rules in making sure that
they are contributing to what the mayor
is asking for everyone to be off of the
streets from 9 p.m. until sunrise so I
thought that that was interesting it was
my first time seeing how beyond downtown
was being impacted by the curfew
absolutely and you know what all right
it's like things are calming down in
Atlanta this is what you want to see the
curfew has started it seems generally
people are walking away we are not
seeing plumes of of gas rising as we
were just 15 minutes ago so that that is
a good sign and hopefully this is the
way it will remain we have a New York
City here up in the upper left we have
Hollywood California Washington DC
Boston the resistance seems to be back
in Boston okay they are back and they
are continuing to walk down what we
believe is Washington Avenue walking by
the recently closed
I believe it's o'doyle's pub is where
they are now I once drove out to this
neighborhood and played soccer at the
field that is over here to the left
probably about to walk by turtle swamp
brewing tremendous brewery excellent
beer I recommend the orange line what's
it called orange line something anyway
they have they have some great beer so
this is an area I've been to although
again it looks like the stream is having
issues the stream is very very much
having issues so maybe we will get away
from it and just be able to keep an eye
on it here in this small box let me say
thanks to a few other folks who just
signed up on my website thank you so
much Pamela Boss signing up as new
member number 35 appreciated Jennie
Eason is new member number 36
Tommy Christian is number 37 at join
pakman.com Donna Godfrey is number 38
while Zachary cost is number 39
thanks to Ryan Anderson you are new
member number 40 today thank you so much
I can't tell you what it means that
folks are understanding what's going on
understanding that Facebook and YouTube
channels are being demonetised when they
talk about real issues like these
protests like what happened with George
Floyd and I really do appreciate
everybody who's been supporting directly
speaking of which huge thank you on
twitch to pink and blonde who is now a
nine month prime subscriber summer vibe
has subscribed crow no mage has
subscribed rebel without a cause is now
in for nine months and Jala hippo says
Trump just tweeted announcing moving the
convention from North Carolina whatever
he also said also do you think
illegality of using military as law
enforcement would actually keep it from
happening if he ordered it
really skeptical of the chances of the
military checks-and-balances standing up
to him I have a video about this where
we talk about the Posse Comitatus Act
and the insurrection act and how they
relate to each other also thanks to
bladdy miaow who subscribed with prime
and says david has always thoroughly
enjoying your objective productive and
thoughtful analysis keep it going thank
you I will do exactly that okay let's
get to some other super chats here John
Lawson grabbed a soy boy membership
Danny Belmonte says have you heard about
the race war that broke out between
Hispanic and black communities in
Chicago following the protests I have
not heard about that I don't know if it
happened but if it did I want to know
more about it I just have not heard
about it yet progressive atheist trucker
says love the show black lives matter
Ciara black sends a super check NH says
the priests at the church says they were
gassed oh they were gassed yesterday in
DC there's no doubt about it
Anthony Lud away says sorry if you've
already answered this how do you think
this will end with peace and actual
change with peace and an uncapped
promise or a devastating tragedy and no
change listen I have
a hard time imagining that these
protests will directly lead to change
the hope would be the protests lead to
organization which often leads to
lawsuits and regulations and sometimes
on the tail end if you look at Brown v
Board of Education in 54 that was a
Supreme Court decision that was the
culmination of three and a half years of
activism which started with protests so
this is a process I guess is the message
that I'm pointing out Joseph Woodward
says thank you so much for sharing John
Howell says outstanding independent
journalism thank you John
Townsend Cox says it'd be interesting to
compare how much has been spent on
police tanks and riot gear versus on
surplus hospital supplies and staff in
the past ten years it would be
interesting it would be an analysis I
guess it would it's it's doable you
would need to uh you need to do it
carefully
Alex Coulson says what are the metrics
of innocent black deaths by police with
Trump versus Obama I don't know and when
you say innocent you know we have a
system that assigns guilt or lack of
guilt it doesn't assign innocence and
that that can make those sort of
questions fraught or difficult in some
sense let me say thanks to Donnie
Darklighter for subscribing over on
Twitch folks asking for a tour of some
of the different feeds we're looking at
so it looks like the Boston feed is done
oh no the Boston feed is back okay
Boston feed is back and a lot of action
happening there this is a New York City
feed it actually does look like the
streets are starting to clear as the
curfew has been in place now for
nineteen minutes in New York City right
in New York City had a 9:00 p.m. curfew
or is it an 11:00 p.m. now I don't
getting my curfew I believe it was a
9:00 p.m. curfew in New York City so
that's going on we have Atlanta
seems to be settling we did have right
around 9:00 p.m. there was a bunch of
tear gas going up and some destruction
of fences as well but it seems like
things by and large are kind of
simmering down
we have Washington DC this is I believe
still near the White House unless the
feed has moved from the Washington Post
and then we also have what appears to
maintain although we now have maybe lost
the feed let's see if we can pick it
back up live in Denver it appears to be
a widely peaceful protest for the time
being although they do seem to be having
some stream issues going on for sure at
this point in time let's see here Jeremy
Landry says curfew is excused to attack
people from new rule jb has grabbed a
beta membership Dylan Collett says will
this will be significantly feared what
hold on will the significantly feared
second wave of kovin cases research much
sooner than the fall or winter given all
of the chaos I don't know the answer to
that obviously I hope not but I am
worried about the effect on the virus of
all of these protests George Soros
Jamaica says saw a couple progressive
youtubers making fun of Joe Biden's
stutter calling him a [ __ ] for it not
sure why they made fun of him for a
speech impediment yeah it's like making
fun of someone for having you know
congestive heart failure or diabetes or
dwarfism I mean it you know I don't I
don't make fun of people for medical
conditions and I I don't know who did
that but I would not do that I it's just
horrible Jim Chamberlain has subscribed
on YouTube David D'Arcy says it seems to
me that Forrest Trump wants to make the
purge a reality from Ireland go Mary and
bothell eat I don't know how to
pronounce Irish stuff Ben Goodall has
signed up
Jorge Zoroaster make did you see those
random pallets of stone or bricks yeah
you know I saw different videos
purporting to be police dropping off
bricks
to make it easier to destroy property
and most of those videos seemed
questionable in terms of what they were
all out of context for ayat for all I
know the videos weren't even from
yesterday so I don't want to say too
much about that because I don't really
know whether the videos are genuine Dan
Matty Enzo says from Plymouth watching
local news and the last I saw state
police are requesting backup in Brockton
keep doing what you're doing man
Casey Reynolds says David do you think
vote-by-mail will be necessary for a
Biden victory if the GOP prevents it
what's your outlook on in-person turnout
listen I don't believe vote-by-mail is
necessary for a Biden victory but
they're very good at suppressing the
in-person vote Republicans are we have a
pandemic we're dealing with I can't
think of any reason not to have
in-person voting okay
Cory Roberts has signed up on YouTube
juvy and official says from an optics
perspective having a conservative
Democratic candidate could be beneficial
given the radical spin mass media has
attributed to protesters I don't know
about that I don't know about that I'd
have to think about that a little bit
more John Howell says agent provocateurs
please caution about the threat very
much so an oxymoron says please plug the
remove qualified immunities act I will
discuss that probably tomorrow and
stabby 666 says I'm wondering if Kyle or
crystal ball will change their minds
about not voting against Trump after
seeing the military brought in by Trump
good question somebody told me they did
tweet some stuff about this and seem to
be going more in the direction of Biden
although I did not see it personally
thank you to Brett Hinchcliffe who just
signed up at join pakman.com really
appreciate that you are new member
number 41 today a fantastic number an
incredible number really also thanks to
our visu diego who has subscribed with
prime over on twitch very very much
appreciate that let's take a look at
some of the other
videos that we have we have it looks
like they're really struggling to keep
the video going in Denver yeah I don't
know what's going on with the Denver
video but it seems to repeatedly just
freeze right where is it here okay so
that video is dead we're going to get
off of that the protests in Washington
DC that coverage seems to have ended we
have let's see what's happening in
Atlanta because last night I think was
not so good no Antonio Brown excuse me
really saying you know the purpose of
this is to remain peaceful and to allow
their voices to be heard but at the same
time they are acknowledging that there
are agitators in the crowd and Ron how
do you really separate the two because
when you fire off tear gas you don't
know who is who you just have to do the
methods that you know will work to
disperse the crowd well you know what if
the reports are true all across our
country and all the various cities that
are many of these folks who are
agitators are not Atlantians they're not
from Chicago they're not from LA these
are outsiders who just are looking for
an opportunity I think the outsider
thing is a bit of a problem because what
they mean by so left and right I'm not
saying this channel is left or right but
left and right are using this these are
outside people to push their agenda so
the right says these are outside people
to imply that the communities where the
protests are taking place are not really
concerned about police brutality and
it's just people coming in from outside
either to Lu door or to make Trump look
bad or whatever the left I think is
generally motivated by pointing out when
Outsiders come in they are the
troublemakers basically arguing that
really these are peaceful protesters and
the community people who live in these
communities are peaceful but it's
Outsiders who are not peaceful and I
understand that I think that we just
have to be careful because even if you
come from the outside you could be
coming from the outside because you live
somewhere rural where there is no
opportunity to demonstrate
straight and you're just going to the
nearest urban center when we talk about
activism one of the things we talk about
is you can maybe get more attention by
scaling up mass rallies at urban centers
you don't do mass rallies rallies in the
countryside so I want to be careful
about this Outsiders thing in all senses
now we from some cities we have arrest
data in many cases sometimes only like
one out of eight arrests or one out of
ten arrests from what I've seen are
people from outside of the place now
does the place mean the city or the city
and the suburbs of the county I don't
know but you know just being an outsider
doesn't mean your your perspective is
any less valid right if you live in
rural northern Indiana and you say well
the protests are in Chicago I care about
police brutality I'm gonna go to Chicago
because nobody's protesting in rural
northern Indiana so so what if okay so
you came from a place where there's no
people and now you're in a city and this
is where the protest is so I think we
should just be careful about allowing
that to be used to disqualify the the
the importance of people getting
together who are from urban areas and
from rural areas and whatever else it's
fine to be from the outside the question
is are you I think the question is are
you there genuinely or are you there to
stir up the crowd and destroy stuff and
create confrontations with police and if
you are I don't care where you're from
whether you're from in the city or out
of the city if that's what you're doing
I don't want you there period that's it
there's really nothing else okay let's
see here been boosting says what do you
make of Val Demmings as a potential VP
so I think that some of the of the black
women whose names are being thrown
around as Biden VP possibilities really
are not likely to be considered so like
I don't think Nina Turner has any shot
at being considered I don't think Stacey
Abrams is seriously being considered Val
Demings is someone you could actually
really look at and I think it would be
very interesting because she has a left
law enforcement perspective former law
enforcement officer I think it would be
very interesting I I still
think that on on policy Elizabeth Warren
is probably the leftmost person that's
being seriously considered right now I
think Chlo Bashar is out after it was
revealed she was against charging Derek
shavon during one of his previous
alleged bad acts so that's that's my
thought I guess okay Ron says that's an
m1117 guardian and Armand armored
vehicle commonly used by military police
definitely not needed for this mission I
think you were referring not to this one
but to the other one point taken though
Johnny lasagna gaming says thank you so
much for saying making fun of stutters
is bad I was tormented all through
elementary school for having a stutter
much love keep it up absolutely so
things are seeming more calm in atlanta
which i think is a good thing that's
what you want to see we have a police
helicopter from new york NBC for over
new york city and it seems as though
things are calming down there as well
and that our boston stream has died so
that is what is going on there and we
want things to be calm that is of course
a very very good thing i'm going to be
wrapping my coverage at the bottom of
the hour just one minute from now i may
be doing these regularly i think it is
important to keep up with what is going
on as you all saw as we looked from
Boston to Atlanta to Denver New York
City Washington etc it is not an
exaggeration to say at least 99% of what
is going on is just peaceful reasonable
protesting period we saw in Atlanta some
people breaking down some construction
fence some of that could have been
people trying to escape the tear gas it
was unclear exactly what came first but
I think it is abundantly clear that the
vast majority of what we are seeing is
peaceful process protesting people
abiding by curfews people mostly wearing
masks etc so thank you for joining me we
will have more coverage on tomorrow's
show don't miss my YouTube segments that
we have uploaded today I really
appreciate everybody joining me